[Musik]
wir kommen zu zdf heute live anders ist
ein paukenschlag im amerikanischen
präsidentschaftswahlkampf 32 tage vor
der wahl hat präsident trump
bekanntgegeben dass er sich mit dem
corona virus infiziert hat er und seine
ehefrau melania was das bedeutet wissen
wir noch nicht wir wissen auch nicht ob
die beiden tatsächlich erkranken ob sie
symptome zeigen wenn ja welche was aber
schon jetzt klar ist ist der präsident
muss in selbstisolation und das bedeutet
auch keine öffentlichen auftritte
zumindest nicht persönlich gemeinsam
wolle man das jetzt durchstehen
twitterte der us präsident und bei ihm
geht es nicht nur um gesundheitliche
fragen die für ihn persönlich jetzt
natürlich sicherlich im vordergrund
stehen es geht auch um politische fragen
allein schon deshalb weil sein corona
management in den vergangenen wochen und
monaten stark in der kritik standen was
er naturgemäß anders
wir hören mal rein in einen der vielen
statements die er gegeben hat wir wollen
keine panik es gibt keinen grund zur
panik
ich habe die grippe ich habe mit ärzten
geredet das ist wie eine grippe menschen
sterben an der grippe es ist sehr
ungewöhnlich es ist ein bisschen anders
in mancher hinsicht leicht ein mancher
schwerer aber wir haben es gut unter
kontrolle
wir haben einen tollen job gemacht das
wirbelt den ohnehin schon recht
aufgeladenen wahlkampf in den usa
durcheinander
und deshalb wollen wir unsere usa
korrespondent in butter je aus
washington dazu holen und mal ein paar
fragen klären
britta arbeiten wir diese fragen mal der
reihe nach ab zunächst schauen wir auf
den gesundheitszustand eine infektion
heißt ja noch lange nicht dass man auch
erkrankt auf deiner seite gehört der
präsident mit 74 jahren zur risikogruppe
was weiß man über den zustand
naja also man weiß dass es ihm recht gut
geht
er hat zeigt wo noch keine symptome er
hat auch gesagt dass es ihm gut geht
melanie hat gesagt dass es ihnen gut
geht und sie das eben ja gemeinsam
durchstehen wollen und er hat auch vor
solange es ihm solange er keine symptome
zeigt die amtsgeschäfte weiter zu führen
das wird er dann eben aus dem weißen
haus machen können müssen was bedeutet
die selbstisolation dir natürlich man
einhalten muss für den wahlkampf und
zwar erst mal aus rein praktischen
gründen was wird jetzt passieren wird er
das rein virtuell gestalten was erwartet
man ja das wird er wohl müssen also
zunächst einmal und das ist das was auch
überall hier jetzt diskutiert wird alle
beobachter auch in den
nachrichtensendern diskutieren natürlich
über die konsequenzen was passiert jetzt
und ein punkt ist natürlich die nächste
tv debatte die an steht am 15 oktober
sollte es ja die zweite debatte geben
zwischen donald trump und joe biden und
die wird es jetzt erstmal so nicht geben
können
genauso wird er auch seinen wahlkampf
nicht mehr so weiterführen können wir
das bisher getan hat und wie er es auch
geliebt hat nämlich erst rausgegangen
und habe sich ja trotz dieses virus bei
wahlkampfveranstaltungen vor massen
anhängern gestellt und das wird er so
nicht mehr machen können das heißt er
wird das ganze jetzt virtuell gestalten
müssen und wir müssen das mal beobachten
wie er das genau macht ja wir wissen ja
auch er liebt das bad in der menge
während joe biden ja schon seit monaten
sehr vorsichtig ist und sein wahlkampf
vor allem von zu hause aus gestaltet auf
der anderen seite ist trump in den
sozialen netzwerken eigentlich sehr
stark und gut also wer wird da vor allem
profitieren was schätzt man ja trump ist
natürlich in den sozialen netzwerken
stark vor allem er gilt ja auch als der
twitter präsident also insofern hat er
da ist sozusagen ist er auch da zu hause
bei social media aber er ist einfach und
das haben wir in den letzten jahren
seiner präsidentschaft gesehen er ist
besonders gut wenn er von menschen steht
er ist auch besonders gut wenn ihm die
cloud also seine seine anhänger zu
jubeln dank dass das pusht
und da fährt er dann auch wirklich
richtig hoch die erfahrung zeigt dass
wenn der veranstaltung hat bei denen er
mit dem teleprompter sprechen muss etwas
ablesen muss beispielsweise da ist er
nicht besonders gut das heißt die tram
kampagne muss sich jetzt überlegen wie
sie wie sie damit umgehen
joe biden hat das jetzt eben schon eine
gewisse zeit gemacht er hat ja seit
anfang der korona krise hatte er jetzt
die ersten monate eigentlich nur einen
virtuellen wahlkampf abgehalten den er
in seinem keller in seiner in seiner
heimatstadt wilmington delaware
aufgestellt hat also an die kamera und
dann saß er da und hat sozusagen ein
ziemlich doch auch langweiligen
wahlkampf veranstaltet muss man sagen
das macht er aber auch ganz bewusst denn
er möchte gerne in diesem wahlkampf der
krasse gegenpol zu donald trump seien
eben nicht der laute eben nicht der
unverschämte nicht der polarisierer
sondern eben komplett das gegenteil das
heißt dieses format kommt ihm eigentlich
auch schon fast ganz gut gelegen
eben weil joe biden auch dafür bekannt
ist dass er sich ab und zu einmal
verhaspelt und weisen nach worten ringt
und so weiter und wenn das alles sehr
kontrolliert ist also sehr virtuell
kontrolliert man man kriegt keine
spontanen fragen von journalisten
beispielsweise dann ist kommt ihm das
eigentlich zugute das heißt so beiden
profitiert eigentlich von der situation
während donald trump jetzt gucken muss
wie er wie er sozusagen es ausgleicht
dass er nicht mehr vor seiner großen
kreis stehen kann
britta wir bekommen ja auch viele
reaktionen von unseren usern und
userinnen und viele bezweifeln dass
trump tatsächlich infiziert ist vermuten
ein wahlkampfmanöver so äußert sich zum
beispiel harmos auf youtube vielleicht
hat ja kein grüner und er will mit der
lüge länger präsident sein weil die wahl
dann verschoben wird was ist an solchen
spekulationen dran
also dass die wahl verschoben wird dass
es eigentlich so gut wie ausgeschlossen
vor allem nicht wenn der präsident
erkrankt also wenn es um so etwas geht
ja es gibt diese gerüchte vor allem auf
social media und warum das alles
entstanden ist liegt wahrscheinlich
daran dass das weiße haus sehr erstmal
sehr zurückhaltend war die nachricht
dass hopes beispielsweise seine enge
beraterin dass die mit dem corona virus
infiziert war und ihn dann eben wohl
auch angesteckt haben soll dass diese
meldung habe nicht vom weißen haus
sondern das wurde anna medien gelegt das
heißt medien kam erstmal damit und die
dadurch entstehen wahrscheinlich auch
solche gerüchte
die new york times berichtet jetzt dass
das weiße haus auch versucht hat diese
nachricht unter den teppich zu kehren
auf der anderen seite glaube ich daran
persönlich nicht denn so ein fake also
wirklich das zu inszenieren dass das
bedarf ja auch das hat ja da gibt es ja
auch mitwisser und diese wird mitwisser
müssen im prinzip alle die klappe halten
und ich glaube das wäre ein tier das
wäre gar nicht machbar so was kommt raus
ich glaube nicht dass das eine feste
britta wir sprechen gleich weiter aber
vorher wollen wir uns einen kurzen
überblick verschaffen über die vielen
aspekte die zusammenhängen mit dieser
meldung donald trump positiv ein
testergebnis mit corona david sauer hat
die einzelheiten und details der wohl
mächtigste mann der welt ist mit 74
jahren risikopatient das weiße haus wird
nun zum quarantäne domizil trumps enge
beraterin hob hicks hatte ihre infektion
kurz zuvor gemeldet sie begleitete ihn
auch in dieser woche über die umstände
von hicks ansteckung mutmaßte trump
gestern in einem telefon interview mit
fox news
die menschen wollen dich umarmen und
küssen weil wir so gute arbeit für sie
leisten da kommt man sich eben näher
trump selbst hatte die gefahr durch das
virus nie wirklich ernst genommen
absolvierte wie vorgestern in cleveland
allen warnungen und teils auch gesetzen
zum trotz wahlkampfauftritte mit
tausenden anhängern und ohne maske
im tv duell am dienstag vereinbarte
trump seinen kontrahenten joe biden weil
der häufig einen mund nasen schutz trägt
dabei grassiert die pandemie in den usa
verheerend mehr als 7,2 millionen
infektionen mehr als 200.000 tote die
infektion des präsidenten verleiht den
letzten vier wahlkampfwochen eine neue
dynamik zu wessen gunsten ist ungewiss
und sicherlich wird die antwort auf
diese frage auch stark davon abhängen
wie stark und ob dort tatsächlich
erkrankt britta jäger in washington oder
ja das ist richtig wir müssen jetzt mal
den weiteren verlauf beobachten bis
jetzt geht es ihm gut aber das hat
natürlich auch weitere konsequenzen für
die amtsgeschäfte beispielsweise wenn
sich jetzt herausstellt dass trump
wirklich schwer erkrankt wer führt dann
diese amtsgeschäfte da gibt es ein
regelwerk da würde sein vizepräsident
joe biden übernehmen für ihn aber job
entschuldigung mike pence entschuldigung
job eines der herausforderer mike pence
ist der vizepräsident mike pence würde
dann die amtsgeschäfte übernehmen
aber mike pence war eben auch in den
vergangenen tagen sehr nahe an trump
dran er war sich in seinem dunstkreis
sozusagen bewegt und es könnte ja sein
dass mike pence auch positiv ist
was macht man also dann wenn die beiden
männer positiv sind und beide männer
beispielsweise erkranken würden dann
würde ganz interessanter weise die
dritte frau im staat zum zuge kommen und
das ist eine demokraten es ist die
sprecherin im repräsentantenhaus das as
nancy pelosi
tja und damit eine der größten
kontrahentinnen von donald trump das
wäre dann in der tat ironie der
geschichte
der präsident steht ja schon seit wochen
und monaten stark unter druck wegen
seines krisenmanagements ihm wird
vorgeworfen
zunächst das virus verharmlost zu haben
dann das ausmaß hat es verglichen mit
einer harmlosen erkältung und er habe
damit wertvolle zeit verstreichen lassen
zu reagieren so der vorwurf
entsprechend hat sich die ansteckung
skore in den usa dargestellt wir schauen
einmal kurz auf diese kurve drauf die
recht steil ansteigt da im juni geht es
hoch und ist immer noch sehr hoch über
200.000 verstorbene 7,2 millionen
infizierte bisher dritter vor dem
hintergrund dieser reaktor dieser
infektionszahlen welche reaktionen hören
sie denn jetzt auf seinen positiven test
wenn es darum geht wie er sein
krisenmanagement bisher gestaltet hatte
also amerika ist ja sehr gespalten
das ist eigentlich zusammen amtszeit
auch noch mal verstärkt worden
und jeder es gibt ganz wenig leute die
im prinzip keine meinung haben und die
man ist entweder für trump oder man ist
im prinzip gegen trump und viel
dazwischen gibt es auch nicht dh was
reaktionen angeht da gibt es natürlich
die einen wünschen genesungswünsche und
wünschen den präsidenten alles gute
hoffen natürlich auf einen ganz milden
verlauf aber es gibt natürlich auf der
anderen seite nehme die liberalen
nachrichtensender
die halten sich aber auch sehr zurück
muss ich sagen sie konzentrieren sich
eher auf die analyse darauf was was
passiert jetzt wie geht es ist jetzt
hier weiter an anstatt weinstadt
sozusagen auf ihnen auf ihn drauf zu
hauen es ist auch ein bisschen häme
dabei natürlich aber ist allen bewusst
dass es natürlich hier um einen mann
geht der über 70 ist und der am corona
virus erkrankt ist ja auch international
gibt es natürlich viele reaktionen die
auch eine große bandbreite zeigen auch
häme ist dabei aber auch viele
genesungswünsche
wir schauen mal auf ein paar offizielle
stellungnahmen und wünsche grüße in
richtung kam damals zum beispiel den
regierungssprecher seibert der sagt
jetzt muss ich mal kurz mit vorbeugen
damit dies auch lesen kann ich sehe ich
sende donald trump und melania alle
meine guten wünsche ich hoffe dass sie
ihre corona infektion gut überstehen und
bald wieder ganz gesund sind das also
regierungssprecher der bundeskanzlerin
dagegen schreibt matteo salvini der
oppositionsführer in italien in italien
wie in der welt gilt wer die krankheit
eines mannes oder einer frau feiert wer
seinem nächsten gar den tod wünscht
entpuppt sich als das was er ist ein
seelenloser idiot eine umarmung für
melania und donald trump das also auch
im hinblick auf diese himmel die
natürlich auch vielfach ausgeschüttet
wird jetzt über den präsidenten
britta hier kommen auch wieder fragen
von nutzern die sich vor allem auf rein
praktische sachen jetzt beziehen zb was
ist wenn donald trump ist zum 15 oktober
immer noch infiziert ist darf dann my
pants mit joe biden debattieren fragt
der eine und ob beide nach dem duell
jetzt auch in quarantäne muss so jetzt
hat der user mich erwischt denn das weiß
ich gar nicht
ich glaube nicht dass sie mike pence mit
joe biden debattieren würde denn die
vize-präsidentin haben ja auch ihre
eigene debatte nächste woche findet sie
statt mike pence gegen camara harris
also die beiden werden sich ein eigenes
duell liefern
und deshalb glaube ich nicht dass der
vizepräsident gern gegen den
herausforderer beiden antreten wird
ich denke man wird da möglicherweise
über andere lösungen nachdenken
vielleicht findet das ganze gar nicht
statt vielleicht wird das verschoben
vielleicht findet man aber auch eine
möglichkeit das virtuell zu lösen das
gibt es ja auch also die nächste
präsidentschaft die die nächste tv
debatte sollte eigentlich in einem art
townhall format stattfinden also nicht
wie die erste debatte sondern und das
bedeutet dass wähler fragen stellen
können die dann eben von beiden
kandidaten beantwortet werden das könnte
man ja theoretisch auch virtuell lösen
da müssen jetzt mal abwarten wie die
kommission sich entscheidet ja ein gutes
beispiel wie viele fragen im moment
offen sind wie ungewöhnlich diese ja
diese diese situation jetzt ist in einem
präsidentschaftswahlkampf in dem es
wahrscheinlich solch eine epidemie noch
nie gegeben hat
der tag wird viele antworten bringen
weitere fragen weitere reaktionen britta
jäger erst mal vielen dank für den
augenblick nach washington
wir werden deshalb den ganzen tag weiter
beobachten was in den usa passiert
welche reaktionen ist noch gibt um 20
uhr 30 melden wir uns deshalb noch
einmal mit zdf heute live bis dahin
einen schönen nachmittag